حسنًا ، أعتقد أننا نفهم ما يثير
اهتمامك ، فهم
فريق جيد جدًا للعب مع 5-3-2
عادةً كما تعلم ، ويلعبون دائمًا
هذا النظام تحت هذا المدرب ، حيث
يمسك المهاجمان بالكرة بشكل
جيد حقًا  ثم لديهم الكثير من العدائين
من خط الوسط والظهير ، لذا فأنت تعلم
أننا نفهم ما هم عليه كفريق
وهم يدافعون جيدًا بشكل لا يصدق ،
لذلك لا نتوقع أن تكون
مباراة مفتوحة ولا أعتقد أن هذا يحدث كثيرًا  في
النهائيات على أي حال ، لذا
أعتقد أنه يجب علينا أن نفهم ألا
نتوتر بسرعة كبيرة جدًا وأنت تعلم أنه
ربما لن يكون هناك الكثير من الفرص في
البداية ولكنك تعلم أنه يتعين علينا
محاولة اللعب بالطريقة التي  افعل وكن
مرتاحًا مع
أمك دون اللعب في اللعبة وبعد ذلك
نأمل أن نجد فرصًا ونبدأ في
صنع الفرص وإحراز بعض الأهداف.